le centre georges pompidou rouvrira ses
portes le 1er janvier prochain après
plusieurs mois de travaux les
conservateurs en ont profité pour
refaire une beauté aux oeuvres exposées
et paradoxe même les oeuvres du xxème
siècle ont besoin d'être restaurée
l'atelier n'a donc pas chômé comme ont
pu le constater nos reporters
marie-claire tiers et guides verts rien
à signaler pour ce tableau de derain
soumis aux ultraviolets westminster
peinte en 1906 mais lors de cette séance
photo qui permet de connaître l'état des
oeuvres et leur vécu on s'aperçoit que
cette toile de fond trier de 1958
intitulé comme tu le sens est vraiment
très altérée partie du spectre texte
ultra violets nous permet de descendre
en dessous de l'art de la couche
extérieure d'une oeuvre est de voir tous
les incidents tous les accidents tout le
vieillissement que l'oeuvre a subi des
examens qui établissent en quelque sorte
le carnet de santé de ses oeuvres du
xxème siècle pour mieux les restaurer il
s'agit d'une couche picturale qui est
très usés qui est lacunaire par endroits
ce qui est des manques de les manques de
peinture tout simplement et qu'il s'agit
réunifiée l'ensemble les matériaux
constituant sont réellement plus
fragiles les sommes effectivement sont
plus vulnérables souvent sans
encadrement que je voulais dire sans
vernis protecteur
donc elles sont vulnérables en ce sens
que les poussières les pollutions
peuvent se fixer les manipulations sont
toujours en lice et une ce pas en mesure
de savoir ce qui va se passer dans 40
ans 50 ans autant de siècle sur des
peintures acryliques sur les toiles non
préparés au synthétique restaurer c'est
aussi retrouver l'état original de
l'oeuvre comme pour cette sculpture de
brancusi la peinture qui est émise après
la mort de brancusi parce que autrefois
comme on ne savait pas vraiment comment
nettoyer les plâtres on repeignait on
avait tendance à mettre un badigeon sur
les plâtres pour qu'ils soient plus
blancs accrochés dans les réserves des
picasso des massifs des duffy attendent
sagement leur tour avant de retrouver
leur place de star dans les lumières du
centre georges pompidou qui ouvrira à
nouveau ses portes le 1er janvier 2011